this morning we have a unique behind the
scenes look at this year's Nickelodeon
Kids Choice Awards our friend Nate will
co-host the show tomorrow night with
social media star Charlie demilio that's
why we haven't seen him this week they
have been busy rehearsing the Kids
Choice Award celebrates fan favorites
from movies TV music Sports and More and
Nate sent us a preview from Los Angeles
where the Nickelodeon team is getting
ready for its big night
[Applause]
with just hours to go until the
Nickelodeon Kids Choice Awards the
inside of Microsoft theater is bustling
with activity
seating charts are being finalized the
Slime is being prepared and the hosts
are working out all the wrinkles that's
all I'm saying I'm saying how she's
saying it
[Music]
social media superstar Charlie demilio
and myself will be bringing the Slime
into your living room this Saturday
night along with some of America's
biggest stars it's going to be chaotic
we have a way for kids to vote like they
can vote in real time their dreams can
come true and then there's also going to
be Salon it's such an honor and such a
great accomplishment to be slimed but
then there's also the shower after where
you're like can I get this out of my
hair this year's award show will feature
new celebrity collaborations stunts and
of course slime
[Applause]
Nickelodeon has been in the Slime
business for decades in the Kids Choice
Awards have been on the air for almost
as long this award means a lot These
Days the show is just a bit more
technical more cameras more celebrities
more slime More Everything Jennifer
Bryson and Paul Medford are Nickelodeon
vice presidents they are in charge of
putting on one of the biggest
Productions in Nickelodeon history like
what's the what's the one thing that
kind of keeps you up at night and you're
like that's going to be tough to pull
off well look there's Talent right you
need big talent in the room true and
then there's time then there's
rehearsals and there's music okay then
there's the set design which has to go
from a piece of paper into this yeah and
then we get here and we're like oh it's
exactly how we thought it was yeah but
and there's always that butt that keeps
you up at night how do we keep it
surprising and how do we just keep
everybody on their feet we've got 2 000
gallons of slime we have a thousand feet
of piping underneath the stage 18
different positions we have a slime dung
tank that's 1600 gallons of slime so
we've got tons of slime and you never
know where it's going to come from or
who's going to get it it's a production
that takes a village and it's an awards
show four kids voted on by kids comedy
icon Adam Sandler will receive the
Show's first ever king of Comedy Award
for his career achievements and
grammy-nominated recording artist BB
rexa will perform but as Charlie tells
us you will need to tune in this
Saturday night for all the surprises
I've got a few tricks up my sleeve that
I am keeping quiet for now so here's the
thing you can watch like the Super Bowl
you can afford to miss a player too but
when you're watching the Kids Choice
Awards no don't go anywhere you got to
see the whole thing for CBS mornings
Nate Burleson Los Angeles
all right I remember when my kids were
little it's the best show on television
for children I can't wait of course
Nickelodeon is part of our parent
company that's Paramount Global the Kids
Choice Awards will Air live on
Nickelodeon tomorrow at seven o'clock
Eastern in the spirit of the show that's
why we're holding this slime right here
shake well shake well I get to slime
somebody right here in the studio will
it be Vlad gutier Tony decouple jerika
Duncan I'm holding something
right now Matt Shelly they're waiting
they're standing by to find out jarika I
sure hate to mess up your lovely outfit
mess that up oh my gosh this morning
we'll be right back